[Music]
so we're here to answer questions about
anthos we have some pretty senior
software engineers and product managers
up on the stage just like what was
stated before we want this to be very
fluid and interactive so definitely
queue up if you have those live
questions but to start off I'm gonna
introduce myself and then we'll go down
the line I'm Robin Braun I'm in the
professional services organization I'm
the global practice lead of the
application development
I sit in Chicago so it's great to be out
here in California and meeting with all
of our customers so how about you guys
introduce yourself and then maybe add a
song that you think represents anthos
okay be versed yeah alright so everyone
I'm spent
I'm one of the founders of sto and I
also work on cloud service mass at
Google and on anthos which services part
of I've been in Google actually for like
13 years worked on a bunch of internal
in the structure this is kind of our
first big push to have a external
product so it's pretty awesome
my the song that I think comes to mind
and I'm not entirely sure why this is
but thunderstruck by ac/dc maybe just
cuz that's how I think people feel when
they learned about all that Anthes will
do for them yeah there you go
Michael hello my name is Michael Rubin I
am a dev lead of GK on-prem which means
like all the engineering bits and pieces
are the the games I get to play with and
I also work a lot in GK in cloud to the
music I guess that makes sense to me is
anyone know the Squirrel Nut Zippers
they're sort of loud cacophonous music
lots of jazz and they have a song called
the afterlife
we've been playing that song a lot to
sort of late nights occasionally working
and beating through the drums and sort
of having lots of fun and the other one
I'm gonna add in is Tom Petty's got one
called something Goods coming I don't
know if anyone knows that one's not one
of his big hits it's kind of that quiet
song that you play when it's late at
night and nothing's working and you need
to make it work
and it basically brings me a lot of
peace and it's helped some other people
- thanks
I'm dance truly I'm a product manager I
work on the service mesh technology so
sto cloud service mesh and of course its
role in anthos I'm going to start with
the prediction that Michael will give
two answers to every question and and
the song that I will go with is a Foo
Fighters song called learn to fly
because I think people are going to do
that with anthos metaphorically speaking
of course so coming from the field with
all of our field implementation security
is a huge concern and rightfully so what
sort of added benefits does anthos offer
our customers from a security
perspective sorry I can take that from
sort of the service communication aspect
Michal Canadians around the
standardization so security actually is
one of the big focus areas of Sto as a
whole and sort of by extension cloud
service mesh so we want to make it
really really simple for people to
secure all of their communication right
like everything should be encrypted in
transit you shouldn't have to worry
about it everything should be safe you
should limit your blast radius right
like zero trust networks kind of all of
that realm of just making security
something you don't have to worry about
anymore that is just taken care of for
you
I think anthos is really gonna provide
that it takes care of a lot of the sort
of nitty-gritty of making sure all that
works making sure these are rotated
sorts are rotated in the right time at
things you know revoked if they need to
be make it all happen the way that it
should and then we actually give you
controls on top of that so you can say
like hey only this thing should be able
to talk to that thing right like only
this application should talk to this
service and that lets you actually
control things at a much better way than
you would with you know typical Network
firewalls right like you don't you're
not saying this IP address is connected
to that IP address you have to go mess
with IP tables rules I'm say this can
talk to that and that's it and that's
how Google has actually been running
things for 15-plus years internally and
and it works really really well and I
think everyone's gonna
like that dan knows me too well working
together a while I have two answers to
this I'm not really sure I like you that
much right now so I kind of bundle
security in sort of two categories
there's the whiz-bang deep understanding
security I think if you take a look at a
lot of the day zero exploits a lot of
them were sort of find or addressed by
Google you know if you want to have fun
check out the work by Michelle or Tim
all Claire a lot of this stuff got
featured in lwn and you can see there's
a lot of deep understanding of what's
really going on in this new space with
containers and security what's nice is
that with anthos when these things are
happening it's really hard to keep track
of micro-service security and what's
going on and that barrier between
containers and the OS we have an
integrated solution that we take care of
that for the user keeping track of your
operating system your container
technology your kubernetes and what
happened the latest release it's hard
it's very hard to keep on track and we
have that expertise you don't have to
worry about it the other part is kind of
more boring part which is keeping things
up to date it's not easy to do with open
source and staying on top of the latest
cv ease knowing which ones are worthy of
upgrade and which ones aren't is
something else that anthos is about so
we've started and designed it from the
beginning to think about upgrade ability
and doing that all the way again down to
the stack with the operating system the
host OS the container OS is and all the
parts of kubernetes that's the part
that's much more of the grind
but it's the piece that you really want
to outsource because you just do that's
about it I don't know if I'm gonna go
through everybody yeah I hate those
panels where everyone says how they feel
today and then you get bored by the last
person and Dan you nailed me too much so
I'm gonna go back to Robin yeah
questions from the audience I don't know
raise your hand if you're a DevOps
person or you work with your CI CD
pipeline the other T in the crowd
so maybe Stan or Mike can you talk to
kind of the value statement
see I see or some of the benefits that
we're incorporating to kind of meet the
customer where they're at so instead of
adding overhead burden to sea-ice
maintaining another CI CD pipeline kind
of the incorporation of into their
pre-existing pipeline so I I gave a talk
earlier to anyone who attend my talk
earlier today this is will be read this
will be refresher for you but for
everybody else this is new this customer
is not using anthos yet but they are
using the different components they're
using gke they're using sto and in the
last six months of migrated about a
hundred and eighty six services from an
on-prem vm based cluster to a gke
cluster using Sto and what's beautiful
is that they didn't change their
developer experiences at all they have a
very good CI CD pipeline and they
changed the output of that CI CD
pipeline which used to take compile a
jar spin up a VM and then deploy that
jar to the VM now instead their
developers still use the same CI CD but
they modified their pipeline so it
produces a container and it deploys that
container into gke
and and the beauty of what they did was
that they already you know they were
disciplined enough to already not have
developers who are off you know SSH into
into hosts to get things involved they
had done some automation and when they
adopted you know kind of changed the
platform completely underneath it didn't
affect their developers and and that's
been a big deal they are now
multilingual where they used to they
could only handle jars before now the
developers use the appropriate language
for the appropriate tool they have
better insight than ever into their
application how it's running
but what would enable that whole thing
was a good robust CI CD pipeline so
we're what we're hearing a lot from
customers across the board is
introducing another technology if you
think about the change for people
process and tools or technology we're
offering a new technology we're offering
a new processes what do we do about the
people aspect how does how does tomorrow
look for customers that are adopting
this curve role change
we want to take incoming questions first
before we good we've got a list here or
do you want to we have no we don't have
any okay so like while you're in the
audience right now these these two
people with red jacket come just to let
you know but like the people here like
dance and myself we have handled like
ugly situations with customers maybe not
always as well as we want but we've
worked in journeyed with the customer
please feel free to ask what's on your
mind and you know I don't think we'd
have the most successful experience
right now if you just hear us tell you
you know a one-way conversation if we
have anybody with some thoughts or even
some humdingers that they think you know
are hard you know please feel free
that's fine that's what we're here for
right now and hopefully you know we'll
be doing this here and if you don't want
to do it right now we'll be at the booth
later if you want at us someone's got
his hand up wonderful oh there we go
brave Saul here yeah hey thank you and
I'll start the ball rolling so we've got
I predict cloud strategy where I work
we're just about to start with Google
but we've got as you're we've got IBM
cloud tell me a little bit more about
how apples gonna help me deploy to all
three clouds and avoid the fragmentation
that kind of goes on if you don't have
something like anthos yeah so it first
of all I think the question that you
asked has to restate it and for people
who maybe didn't hear it too is that you
have an environment right now that's
Azure IBM and maybe Google to you know
just about to start Google how do you
keep consistency among these three
different environments that have a very
different stack so there's no silver
bullet to anything and I'm not gonna
pretend there is it depends on where you
are in your journey if you are very
container in kubernetes ready right now
the neat thing about anthos today is
that you can deploy kubernetes across
them and have a consistent interface and
API that'll be able to abstract out a
whole bunch of the components in these
environments I mean that's one of the
big values of kubernetes that you can
manage your hardware environment and
your software environment life cycle in
a consistent way with some yeah Mille as
opposed to actually making code changes
what's also nice about what we're doing
we're here with anthos is that
it allows you to be providing tools to
actually do rollout configuration and
other items that are again consistent
like consistency in choice is really
some of the big points behind anthos so
I encourage everyone there's this thing
we haven't talked about as much I think
in the keynotes in other areas Antos
config management which is basically how
do we use git leverage that and yeah
Mille to allow you to handle all these
environments and resources at different
levels keep it straight and then deploy
it selectively so I could go and talk
about this forever because it's a
complicated and complex problem but if
you take a look at the offering sorry if
you take a look at the offering you
should be able to see that the
consistency of the API and the the goals
of making sure that we are abstracting
away multi-cloud you know our identity
story risk quite heavily on o IDC as
opposed to you know deeply diving into
her environment specific api's is the
thrust and the theme behind the
technology does that answer your
question okay
for those not seen it he's kind of
nodding like he bought it which is good
yeah I was gonna add something I don't
know so this is what I want to say is
that today I heard someone on stage say
with anthos you can finally you know
write once and run anywhere and you know
any developer says well I can write code
and run it anywhere today right I can
take Python and Python runs the same at
Google as it does it Azure as it does at
IBM right the thing is that everything
around that running code how you network
to it how you authenticate all of that
is very different at IBM and in Azure
and and in Google and on your on-prem
and the idea with anthos is making all
of that consistent so that everything
around that can be the same no matter
whether you're deploying to to Google or
to IBM or Azure or Amazon and and it's
that consistency that that I think we're
helping to give you I was just gonna add
that I think actually anthems also can
help you with moving things around
between your different environments too
so if you you know install anthos and
all the environments and it's really
easy to you know spin up something in a
different place see how it performs
route one percent 10% and whatever
amount of traffic to it you know compare
things do all that kind of stuff and you
can actually sleep seamlessly move
things
between clouds between kubernetes and
bm's right wherever you want without
anything else having to know about it so
that's really useful I like that one
is there another I mean if they don't
have anything on their mind you know
where Sun got his clothes that's fine
you see Robin I know Robins got more but
I'm sorry you sir I'm here closer to the
mic is there CD system that's sort of
built into anthos or or proposed to use
without those continuous deployment so
the continuous deployment space right
now is in sort of an interesting
transformational pivot point and it
looks like you know for the longest time
Jenkins has been what people have been
using as an automation structure and
it's kind of like the bash script of
being able to handle sequential events
and right now as people are moving into
the cloud the elastic nature of the
cloud and the more sophisticated needs
of concurrency as we scale is creating
this really interesting opportunity I
think for all the technologies it's kind
of fun to watch you know yet but what
got us all here is not going to get us
there and so right now Google has not
you know we have our opinionated
conversations and technologies that
we're offering but at the same point we
do what I think we do well we're trying
to make the space successful so there's
this thing out there that I learned
about like a few weeks ago called the
the continuous delivery foundation which
is yet another Linux Foundation
organization that is supposed to make
the open-source world look good and you
know have us all work together and we
recently donated something called Tecton
to it which is based again upon the same
sort of things that we believe will
allow us to like I said take things the
next level allow us to scale and allow
us to have a different API system so
that's a good piece of technology to
look at right now
but that said anthos is very compatible
so it will work with Jenkins it will
work with other solutions and I don't
know if anyone really has a clear winner
for the next five years of where the
industry and the conversation is going
to go but what's nice about anthos is
you have choice you have less risk that
when you take em those these api's are
flexible enough that you're not locked
in and to me when I'm building large
systems are gonna last a long time
that's what's valuable so I can sort of
hedge my bets a little bit and see where
I want to put my cleverness beans you're
smiling so again I feel like it's
working or not all right can you talk
about how you connect to Jenkins in the
marketplace how do you connect Jenkins
to the marketplace
so I heard how do you connect Jenkins to
a platypus to the marketplace I don't
know if our marketplace has api's that
would allow you to do that automated
fashion I'm not sure so we have we're
about do about 15 or 20 or so absent
available in the marketplace so Jenkins
is one of those things that we're
leading with as a premier partner that's
available and we have api's available so
if you're already a Jenkins customer you
can continue to use Jenkins via a
marketplace for anthos any other live
questions anyone I guess they did a
really good job in the keynote so well
that they told everybody everything they
need to know how many of you are using
gke in production today oh I see so it's
a small number of people okay how many
of you are using VMs in production today
what have the rest of you use are people
using kubernetes that is not gke it's
mostly as/400 mainframe developers here
there's some goober Nettie's yeah yeah
so I'm engaged with a lot of customers
across the globe and we have-we have
kind of like the entire stack and we're
talking about product by product but if
you really think about just like the the
one or two game-changing effects of the
entire stack of anthos what are things
that you would highlight your made it
going yeah yeah okay so we can do the
boring let go no that's important so
actually I'll let you guys go oh I'll
think about it
so I'll start by talking a little bit
more about that customer who I talked to
who talked with today and they kind of
related their their journey to gke and
sto and again they're not on anthos yet
but they're already seeing these
benefits in addition to things like
their spending has gone down
their resources consumption has gone
down and and they have M TLS they've
been much better security than they used
to the real benefit to them is that
there are 350 services they used to do a
total of about I think they said 400
deployments a year right deployments
were a big deal lat vist this year right
now they're on pace to do 15,000
deployments and for them the difficulty
in doing a deployment you know many of
these teams were deploying quarterly in
the past now they have people who are
they're deploying constantly and they
said that they the the fiscal year
they're just finishing is 15,000 next
year they think it'll be 30 and so one
of the benefits is moving to this this
real micro services based environment
you can move very quickly and for them
above all else that's that's the biggest
thing they're getting out of it so ok if
I go next and then and then you go so I
was actually just thinking back to
something that Eric Brewer said in a
talk recently when he was talking about
SEO but so one of these this new does is
it helps you D couple sort of the
development tasks from the operation
tasks it might still be the same person
doing them right but they're they're
very distinct when the amp anthos does
for you is take all those operation
tasks and help you automate them so you
you just can focus on the development
part this sort of fun part at least for
me you don't that you don't the do as
much to do the operations you don't have
to manage all the services and keep them
up and give them SLA days and all that
kind of stuff so I think that's the big
game changer for me is that that
decoupling and then automation so the
more that we can well the more that we
can take away from sort of the things
that you don't want to be doing and just
automate that make it all built into the
platform make it easy to control and let
you focus on your business and what you
want to do the better and that's I think
a big part of the anthro story
businesses now are pretty much in the
inner race for software and software
iteration so I was surprised I was
talking to a tire company and they said
we want to be a services company and let
you sell tires they go no no we sell
tire services and what this really means
to me is they want their software to
iterate and be competitive software to
me is just just imagining things and
what you want in your company is the
developers to focus on imagining
things that only are specific to your
company your applications and the value
that you can get out of them to focus on
what your company's to do to do to be
successful if you have them also
spending a lot of their time managing
and focusing and developing the
infrastructure I find it hard to
understand how you're gonna be as
competitive and because someone else out
there may outsource that or have someone
else do that and you know this is what
we're trying to do to provide for the
customer I met this really great person
once a customer who said I don't want my
engineers tinkering with kubernetes or
tinkering with all this infrastructure
over and over and over again we want
them to come to you with what needs to
be better and then work with you to
improve it while they focus on solving
our problems and I think that this sort
of partnership is really what anthos is
about and I know it's a little cliche
and a little weird and a little abstract
but it's really where do you want to
spend the cleverness beans in your
organization where do you want to have
your focus and so with anthos if you
look at the problems it's tackling
configuration management cluster
management application lifecycle service
mesh you know how involved do you want
to be in the open-source management of
these items and how much of it you want
to leverage others to shape and focus
that work we have a live question yep
hey so how you configure I mean the by
definition you said it's Yahoo and like
a us seem like a pretty real
configuration could be like a huge file
or something like that I'm curious like
a probably you have some SDK or
something like that
well I can talk about anthos config
management so anthos has the question
the question was
Antho sounds like there's a lot of
configuration it is is that is it a big
huge yamo file and in reality it's worse
than that
it's it's many many huge EML files and
you know in reality I want to be clear
right
yamo is one one of the the great things
about kubernetes is its API but the the
primary interface of that API is is
llamó when I see very successful
implementation
though they aren't making their
developers go go right that yeah mow the
Vino I see the I see very successful
implementations where the CI CD pipe
life itself can can take the intent from
the developer which might be a very
simple config file and and Express that
in yeah mo so in some ways I think of
yah mo is that as the bytecode of the of
the cloud native foundation right no one
writes bytecode you write in
higher-level
higher-level languages and so it may be
very well that that you have a simple
config file that says deploy me in two
regions right and deploy me with with
you know five five replicas and that
what comes out the other end is some
yeah Mille that goes into that goes into
the config management and and effects
that change one thing that we can do is
we can take this the the anthos config
management can make sure that your that
that configuration is consistent across
your you know if you are running
multiple clusters that it can make sure
that you have the the correct policies
and the correct yeah mo essentially in
the right places so in reality if you
think about all the all the different CR
DS that are involved in a kubernetes
implementation that yeah Mel can be can
be daunting but in in a in a real
practical application you might not need
to expose that to your developers and
and and that that sounds kind of
outlandish but but I know customers with
very successful implementations where
that's exactly what they did was they
abstracted away the actual yamo itself
anyone I had one thing there which is
that be the API is for anthos are just
the open source API is for kubernetes
and sto and and the other components
there there is not a proprietary API
here which means all of your
configuration is portable right you can
spin it all up if you want to run it
yourself and all your all your
applications and configurations will be
portable to that so we don't have a
proprietary you know Google developed
API that we're using for all this it's
just the open-source api's their product
anthos configuration management it takes
longer to say than to appreciate and
probably to use so there was a demo
yesterday at the multi cloud session i
encourage you to check it out in
the middle of that demo of how to deploy
things across multi-cloud they had like
a 90 second piece or they used anthos
configuration management and it was
really straightforward it was really
easy to see how they took the various
configuration and then deployed it
selectively and honestly I kind of think
that we're talking about it in a way
that highlights its importance but the
ease of use with what that team put
together is to me was surprising and
when I finally saw the demo I was like
oh oh this isn't that big a deal at all
and so it's worth checking out instead
of trying to have us here convince you
take a look at that demo I know that I
talked to the tech lead there's gonna be
more demos coming out about anthos
config management and I think it's one
of these things that when you see it
it's a lot easier to understand that the
problem space doesn't have to be that
hard we have another live question in
the back I don't think it's work can you
comment on on just the right path to get
started all right what's the right way
to train to learn to evaluate I assume
it's not free so somehow we have to take
great or we have to go from our
production care relays environment
introduced prove it out and implement it
so maybe just comment on what that path
looks like so I'm really excited to talk
about this because i think iíve had a
lot of learning in this area it's really
easy to look at all this open source
technology and get excited about just
the technology and I think you leave out
two really important ingredients or
components of the solution people and on
top of that the problem you're trying to
solve and what I've learned is that
instead of going from the bottom up and
saying what am i vm's look like what is
my kubernetes look like what's the
footprint I need I think it helps a lot
first to understand that the people
you're trying to solve not just your
customers but your organization and what
the flow of that organization is going
to be I tend to think that what we're
doing here we have app developers we
have pluster administrators or resource
administrators then we have
infrastructure administrators and
understand their needs and then
understand the needs and the shape of
the applications and I find that if you
don't do that first if you instead focus
all the whiz-bang cool fun toys you're
gonna find that you may have built
something that feels really good but
doesn't really solve your problem and I
think once you do that once you know the
shape of the footprint what success
looks like whether success metrics look
like not just in the end solution of
what you write but the operating life
cycle of what you're doing I think that
helps a lot
the last thing is what's nice about
anthos and I think the really great
thing that kubernetes helps you with is
it embeds the idea of the lifecycle of
your solution into almost all the api's
so it's rarely just about provisioning
it's also about managing and then
decommissioning and upgrading and if you
understand the problem you're solving
the people you're dealing with
and all the lifecycle of them first I
think you'll start finding that the
technology piece is almost fall out of
that very easily I don't know if that's
more so I can be more specific if you
want yeah so how do you get started with
anthos go first so everything that Mike
said you don't have to do alone myself
and they're actually a quite a few of my
team members in the crowd professional
services has been teaming up with engine
p.m. very closely over the last year and
a half or so to really understand the
technology and frame out like what are
what are the best practices what are the
gotchas what are the pitfalls going
through everything from the installation
of g/km from if you want to do an
on-prem installation all the way through
the stack config management CSM or the
service mesh layer even looking at
things like k native and cloud run your
your entire deployment pipeline also so
we're we're deeply involved in all of
those things you don't have to do it
alone you can you can partner in with us
and we would be very willing to to do
that journey with you and bringing up
the kubernetes environment has been
happening a lot faster than the
customers have expected so far so again
I don't want to make a guarantee or a
promise on stage or even not on stage
but so far the customers have been very
very happy with how long it takes from
going from the initial environment to
actually bringing up a cluster because
ESO is trained and the software has been
shaped well by people have been
doing this for a while so getting that
cluster up and going first baby starting
with a stateless workload and then
working from there based in your
requirements is probably a good way to
get started and playing with
configuration management I really can't
overstate how you understand that
involve it in your workflow early can be
helpful to train we do have to we have
to force our courses that are being made
available so our training team does work
with our technical ease to roll out
their architecting with gke for those of
you that need UK experiences hands-on
experiences and this was have hands-on
Lavin and all the second pieces
architecting hybrid with anthos so that
we may available in a couple months so
you can look out for those coastal
courses I think we have time for one
last live question does anyone have a
live question there yeah so it sounds
like what I've heard from okay so what
I've heard in the keynote was this is a
multi cloud solution but word purely in
GCP is it something that we should be
looking at if we're going through the
whole decomposition effort and what does
it really give us that we should look at
so absolutely yes right so this is this
is about managing your stuff wherever it
is if it all happens to be in GCP
already awesome thank you but yeah it's
it's gonna give you the security it's
gonna give you the networking you know
gke gives you a great container
management the config manager portion of
anthos is still useful if you run you
know anything more than one cluster
right if you have VMs and and clusters
you should do that so yeah absolutely
it's it's useful even if you're just on
GCP our success master flat our success
metric I can say that quickly is
consistency and choice so if we end up
inadvertently doing something that is
only going to work in cloud or only
going to work on Prem
that's something that we feel we need to
evolve past and the idea here is that it
isn't something that you should
hopefully have to worry about
architecting in overtime and that that's
it and I think let's close this out and
then before I do that just to note all
of us will actually be at a booth with a
bunch of other anthos SMEs right behind
this red community corner sign so if you
have other questions that you want to
ask one-on-one or if you want to
continue the engagement with
professional services or something
directly with product or engineering
please ask us there but just for a close
out how about one piece of advice moving
forward for all these customers dan you
answer well I would say that as you as
you look
thinking about think about why you're
doing it and and what your metric of
success is and you know if you're if
you're if your goal is to do more
deployments it's a great thing to
measure
then then make sure as you go through
that implementation that that's the
thing you're you're you're measuring and
and you know know what you're trying to
do go ahead you don't implement the
technology just for technology
understand what it is you're trying to
change and and make sure that you're
tracking that so I think my my biggest
piece of advice would be to really think
about what you sort of what Dan said but
think about what you want to pay for
right as as a developer as a business
owner whatever role you have what parts
do you want to pay for and what parts do
you want you know someone else to run
for you and I think anthos is is here
for the hopefully most of you that
realized that yeah you know I don't need
to be an expert in running hundreds of
thousands of kubernetes clusters or in
managing encryption keys and you know
handling zero-day exploits and all that
kind of stuff that we can handle for you
right so so think about where where you
are providing value and focus on that
this is way too much pressure one piece
of advice
listen watch the community now has
gotten quite wide there are many people
that I've noticed that I'm engaging with
they're very rarely have I seen a unique
problem set and so talk to each other
listen to each other and talk to us and
listen to us and realize that right now
I think the world is making a large
transition and as we're moving from one
environment of on-prem into cloud again
I guess I'm in a cliche mood today we
really are all doing it together and so
what I like a lot about multi-cloud is
that we are we are figuring it out all
at the same time and the evidence and
the Internet and the support is really
everywhere and so that's what we're
trying to provide an anthro stance why
working with open source can be you know
so game-changing that's it thank you I
think just just really quick I I'm not
so saddened to this that I'm going to I
work directly with a lot of customers
and one thing I see is a lot of
customers try to boil the ocean don't do
that experiment iterate focus on maybe
like a co e and your companies that you
can make those changes and adjustments
really quickly and then the other thing
is be vocal these are this is a fraction
of the team that's building this product
for all of you it's a product is not
serving your use case or your business
need be vocal with professional services
or your partners or whoever you're
working with and you can really you can
really pay the way of what the products
going to look like in the future so
don't boil the ocean experiment iterate
fast and then be vocal
[Music]